we were talking about the prospect of
this people's vote or a second
referendum however you want to call it
it's not something you want to see well
I want the conference to be able to
debate it you know one of the things
that Jeremy and I said when we were
elected three years ago was we want to
give the party back to its members and
I've been very pleasantly surprised by
the number of constituencies are
submitted resolutions this year there's
over a hundred on this area there in a
room now discussing what we call
conversating and I want the conference
have a good debate on it are you worried
that there might be a bit of a punch but
it's not it won't be a clear-cut votes
picked the conference bill there's
always a danger when you have sort of
resolution based democracy but you know
breaks it's such a binary issue that I
think the debate will be you know
there'll be all sides of the argument
and and when it comes to a second
referendum I'm sure there'll be words on
offer that will either party to come to
the fixed view on that do you think some
people listening to that will think this
is the beginning of the great betrayal
you're listening to labour members who
yes overwhelmingly support the idea of a
second referendum
what about labour voters in places like
your constituency in West Bromwich you
voted to leave the EU and now see this
is effectively politicians ditching it
up so they don't get to have their say I
understand we're conservative opponents
might say that but for us you know but
our opponents carry to us a debate is
that what I hope we can do
we're a democratic party we've got half
a million members
it's just conservatively I mean I've
spoken to as well well here me am
because I talked to you know I talked
about Alexis regulate in West Bromwich
and I'm what I'd say to them is well as
a as a national political party like the
country we are all for all flavours have
brigs it on offer and but the point is
it's not just an to me and Jeremy Corbyn
anymore to decide what our party is
weaved eminent in U&E democratized
it's now to our members to decide and I
hope that I could say to my voters
whatever our Congress decided it's a
democratic decision and if they vote for
a position that means we have to go for
a people's phone then the argument would
be we want more democracy now let me say
though and I feel I do need to say this
that is not the view that Jeremy and I
take what we have said and still want
the converse of support is that there is
a meaningful voting Parliament on the
brexit deal and if we can't get a
meaningful vote then there should be a
general election which would give all my
voters in West Brom it and the rest of
the country their say in a general
election - very hard to argue against
more democracy I think so if you want to
have a general election and we're gonna
happy having this vote and very shortly
and on breakfast should it be in the
Labor Party manifesto then that Labour
would offer a people's vote or a second
referendum if that's what conferences
well we decide our manifesto in the
first few days of a general election and
there are a lot of things you need to
factor in they provide an economic crock
climate the whole other packages in
there he seems to be inconceivable that
if the labour party democratically
decides they were fighting Congress
decides it wants a manifesto Bojana
people's vote that we would defy that
decision
aren't already in the boundaries of
talking hypotheticals with the I think
we need to have the debates of the
conference and see what our delegates
decide to do we need to understand that
you want to listen to the debate but at
the same time it's fair enough to push
you on these things because at the
minute we are running out of time aren't
we on breakfast it's time for people to
come forward and openly say what they
think so what's your what's your view
that if there was to be a second offer
Endon should the option of staying in
the EU be partner well we certainly have
to consider it and if the conference
sense is that message I think we
consider it very strongly but for me
it's important we can unite around a
manifesto commitment as a whole party
you know it's like it's likely but there
are put in an insurance policy in there
because you know it's not me that
decides the manifesto we've got a thing
called the tall's 5 meeting and we would
have to discuss the political landscape
when hits us and let's not forget this
could be any day now
after Saltzburg on Thursday this
newspaper reports that leading
politicians in the Conservative Party
are sort of mapping out what a November
general election would look like this
country this government is on the verge
of collapse
we could have another general election
basically around brexit that's why this
conference is it's vital that we unify
and that we have a strong solid program
we can offer the country at the end of
it
Kait question and as we're talking about
the possibility of a second referendum
how would you go to them on a second
before it was a second I thought remain
in the last referendum I think it is
highly likely that I'd probably vote
remained in the next one but I would
look at what what the question is on
offer and I'd want to know what the deal
is that comes out of the comes out of
the negotiations in Europe if that
happens okay now on keys talked about
and other issues around early party
conferences and a lot of talk hasn't
there about mandatory Rhys elections
there's a vote at the National Executive
Committee that effectively makes it
easier for party members to re select
their local MPs is there something that
worries you it doesn't make me feel
uncomfortable but believe it or not what
came out the National Executive
Committee is a compromise my view was
that the status quo provide I was with
John McDonald on that one but like I say
we're a Democratic Party we've got a
different view there is a rule change on
the order paper that would have full
mandate weari selection and I think that
would be very destabilizing for the
party because you know we're potentially
close to a general election maybe any
day what we don't want is MPs trying to
defend their positions in their local
areas when they could be campaigning in
Parliament for Social Policy that
affects the many not the few so I'm
worried about it are you worried that
there might be a bit of a toxic
atmosphere in the labour party I mean
there's been reports today about a
Labour MP who is going to be needing
armed security as they go around their
daily business I mean this is really
worrying stuff isn't it it's extremely
worrying and please don't forget that
we've also had a colleague assassinated
in the last few years so those security
threats to my colleagues particularly my
female colleagues is very real and very
serious
much of that has very little to do with
the activities of local labor parties or
Labour Party members it's external
bodies Islamist and far-right products
but never nevertheless I am concerned
you know we had some of our younger
newer MPs who sort of face folks have no
confidence and the parties have got the
right to express their disappointment in
their MPs if they want it and I always
think my own members have earned the
right to shout at me when they think I'm
doing things wrong and they've they
frequently have done over the last 17
years but if it goes too far the people
feel alienated all the morale goes or
they're driven out it stops at aiming
for the main prize which is a Labour
government for the many not a few with
the transform political economy that can
really give greater opportunity that's
millions of people that have lost out in
globalization so the tech change and
over the last 20 years the pie is not
work is not being cut enough for them so
you know let's focus on what unites us
let's try and get a manifesto we could
be proud of again and let's get to a
general election as a United Party
calling for the party tonight but the
slightly brutal truth is all the
membership we're going to listen to
because the problem is many of the
memberships some of the membership see
you're part of the problem you're the
enemy
you're not supported enough of Jeremy
Corbyn well there's always a small
number of members but whom you could
never satisfy and with five hundred
fifty thousand members everyone's got a
beer but actually my experience of going
out and campaigning for the party in all
parts of the country is it was when we
recruited lots of young new members at
first it was a bit of a culture clash as
you know more experienced members were
sort of quite challenged by that but
they worked it out and they're all
getting on and lots of loot lots of the
divisions between the leadership and
membership of one side in the
parliamentary Labour Party on the other
well in the parliamentary Labour Party
you know we we have had some bad
behavior from some of my colleagues but
actually my take on the parliamentary
Labour Party since the general election
is their united - they want Jeremy as
Prime Minister they want the party
marching in the same direction and they
want us to get to a general election
with a program we can all unite around
and be proud of
we're a broad Church we know that only
at that to win elections every voice of
the Labour Party's gotta get its boys
her that's my challenge that's Jeremy's
challenge and that's what we're going to
be trying to doing this week another
we've talked a bit about the National
Executive Committee another decision
that they took was to create a second
deputy leader spot to reserve for a
woman I mean it sounds like your power
is about to be home no I've been there
actually I've been calling for this
since the first deputy leadership letter
because gender representation is not
strong enough in Parliament and actually
and in the labour part we've we've still
got more women MPs and all the other
parties put together but Jeremy and I
want 50 percent representation
at the next election and actually one of
the things that I found very useful
aspecty leader is to have a my own
mandate from the membership and I know
people are worried about having three
people around the shadow cabinet table
who have their own mandate I know some
people are worried about what could what
they see that could be a damaging one
member one vote election with all sorts
of different candidates in a second
deputy leadership thing but I think he's
only good for the party and I think it's
good for women's representation and
that's why I argue for it at the NEC do
you want the next Labour leader I
absolutely do yeah I mean I don't want
there to be a new Labour leader or even
a leadership election anytime soon but I
think when Jeremy finally stands down as
Prime Minister
he should be replaced I think no I think
the party has got the rules and we're
changing the rules to do that but I
think that it seems to me that the time
is why the Labour to choose a woman to
lead us to terrible now we talked about
earlier interview about the need for the
party to unite one of the issues that
has been extremely divisive is
anti-semitism and perhaps it's one
reason why despite the crisis in the
brexit talk to the internal arguments
and the conservative party labour has
effectively been stagnating in the polls
you haven't managed to pull ahead
because you spent all this time
introspectively looking at some of your
own problems so can you tell me how many
unresolved cases are there complaints
when it comes to and
or futsal at lycée we have been too slow
and we should have acted more quickly
and that's been advised by Jeremy John
McDonald and myself and actually now
that we've reached the point where we
have we'd adopt a standard international
definition of anti-semitism
we've also significantly increased the
number of staff that deal with these
pathological cases I don't know the
exact number because well because
there's a sort of quasi judicial role
played and this these things can always
end up in the courts and so it's a song
about some student it really it's
surprising to be honest that you don't
it's hard to explain this but I do care
about for every individual case is a
quasi-judicial case and you can't expect
the leader in deputy leader all sort of
front benchers to sort of know the
detail of every since you know how many
people have been expelled and I don't
I'm afraid and I but I've asked for it
and the committee that deals with this
is but is very protective office because
it has to be legally watertight what it
does so but our general secretary it
assures me that the backlog of cases
that she inherited when she took over
has now been processed the committee
that looks at it is it has many many
live cases and I would hope that very
shortly they'll be reaching results on
allegations made against some pretty
disturbing characters